The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
MITOpenCourseWare@OCW.MIT.edu.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: It's
because if I was not,
this would be basically the
last topic we would ever see.
And this is arguably, probably
the most important topic
in statistics, or at
least that's probably
the reason why most of
you are taking this class.
Because regression
implies prediction,
and prediction is what people
are after to now, right?
You don't need to
understand what
the model for the
financial market
is if you actually
have a formula
to predict what the stock
prices are going to be tomorrow.
And regression, in a way,
allows us to do that.
And we'll start with a very
simple version of regression,
which is linear regression,
which is the most standard one.
And then we'll move on to
slightly more advanced notions
such as nonparametric
regression.
At least, we're going to see
the principles behind it.
And I'll touch upon a little bit
of high dimensional regression,
which is what people
are doing today.
So the goal of
regression is to try
to predict one variable
based on another variable.
All right, so here the
notation is very important.
It's extremely standard.
It goes everywhere essentially,
and essentially you're
trying to explain why
as a function of x,
which is the usual y
equals f of x question--
except that, you know, if
you look at a calculus class,
people tell you y equals
f of x, and they give you
a specific form for f,
and then you do something.
Here, we're just going
to try to estimate
what this length function is.
And this is why we often
call y the explained variable
and x the explanatory variable.
All right, so we're
statisticians,
so we start with data.
All right, then what
does our data look like?
Well, it looks like a
bunch of input, output
to this relationship.
All right, so we have
a bunch of xi, yi.
Those are pairs, and I can do
a scatterplot of those guys.
So each point here has a
x-coordinate, which is xi,
and a y-coordinate,
which is yi, and here, I
have a bunch of endpoints.
And I just draw them like that.
Now, the functions we're
going to be interested in
are often function of the form
y equals a plus b times x, OK.
And that means that this
function looks like this.
So if I do x and
y, this function
looks exactly like a line,
and clearly those points
are not on the line.
And it will basically
never happen
that those points are on a line.
There's a famous
T-shirt from, I think,
U.C. Berkeley's
staff department,
that shows this picture
and put a line between them
like we're going to see it.
And it says, oh,
statisticians, so many points,
and you still managed
to miss all of them.
And so essentially, we don't
believe that this relationship
y is equal to a plus bx is true,
but maybe up to some noise.
And that's where the statistics
is going to come into play.
There's going to be some random
noise that's going to play out,
and hopefully the noise is
going to be spread out evenly,
so that we can average it
if we have enough points.
Average it out, OK.
And so this epsilon here is not
necessarily due to randomness.
But again, just like we did
modeling in the first place,
it essentially
accounts for everything
we don't understand
about this relationship.
All right, so for example--
so here, I'm not going to be--
give me one second, so we'll
see an example in a second.
But the idea here is
that if you have data,
and if you believe
that it's of the form,
a plus b x plus
some noise, you're
trying to find the line
that will explain your data
the best, right?
In the terminology
we've been using before,
this would be the most likely
line that explains the data.
So we can see that
it's slightly--
we've just added
another dimension
to our statistical problem.
We don't have just x's,
but we have y's, and we're
trying to find the most likely
explanation of the relationship
between y and x.
All right, and so
in practice, the way
it's going to look like is that
we're going to have basically
two parameters to
find the slope b
and the intercept
a, and given data,
the goal is going to be to try
to find the best possible line.
All right?
So what we're going
to find is not
exactly a and b, the ones that
actually generate the data,
but some estimators of those
parameters, a hat and b hat
constructed from the data.
All right, so we'll see
that more generally,
but we're not going to go too
much in the details of this.
There's actually
quite a bit that you
can understand if
you do what's called
univariate regression
when x is actually
a real valued random variable.
So when this happens, this is
called univariate regression.
And when x is in rp for p
larger than or equal to 2,
this is called
multivariate regression.
OK, and so here we're
just trying to explain y
is a plus bx plus epsilon.
And here we're going to have
something more complicated.
We're going to have y, which is
equal to a plus b1, x1 plus b2,
x2 plus bp, xp plus epsilon--
where x is equal to--
the coordinates of x are
given by x1, 2xp, rp.
OK, so it's still linear.
Right, they still add
all the coordinates
of x with a coefficient
in front of them,
but it's a bit more complicated
than just one coefficient
for one coordinate of x, OK?
So we'll come back to
multivariate regression.
Of course, you can write
this as x transpose b, right?
So this entire thing here,
this linear combination
is of the form x
transpose b, where
b is the vector that has
coordinates b1 to bp.
OK?
Sorry, here, it's in [? rd, ?]
p is the natural notation.
All right, so our goal
here, in the univariate one,
is to try to write
the model, make sense
of this little twiddle here--
essentially, from a
statistical modeling question,
the question is going to be,
what distributional assumptions
do you want to put on epsilon?
Are you going to say
they're Gaussian?
they're binomial?
OK, are you going to
say they're binomial?
Are you going to say
they're Bernoulli?
So that's going to be what we
we're going to make sense of,
and then we're going
to try to find a method
to estimate a and b.
And then maybe we're
going to try to do
some inference about a and b--
maybe test if a and b take
certain values, if they're
less than something,
maybe find some confidence
regions for a and b, all right?
So why would you
want to do this?
Well, I'm sure all of you have
an application, if I give you
some x, you're trying
to predict what y is.
Machine learning is all
about doing this, right?
Without maybe trying
to even understand
the physics behind
this, they're saying,
well, you give me
a bag of words,
I want to understand whether
it's going to be a spam or not.
You give me a bunch of
economic indicators,
I want you to tell me how much
I should be selling my car for.
You give me a bunch of
measurements on some patient,
I want you to predict
how this person is
going to respond to my
drug-- and things like this.
All right, and often we actually
don't have much modeling
intuition about what the
relationship between x and y
is, and this linear thing is
basically the simplest function
we can think of.
Arguably, linear functions
are the simplest functions
that are not trivial.
Otherwise, we would just say,
well, let's just predict x of y
to be a constant, meaning
it does not depend on x.
But if you want it
to depend on x, then
your functions are basically
as simple as it gets.
It turns out, amazingly, this
does the trick quite often.
So for example, if
you look at economics,
you might want to assume
that the demand is
a linear function of the price.
So if your price
is zero, there's
going to be a certain demand.
And as the price increases,
the demand is going to move.
Do you think b is going to
be positive or negative here?
What?
Typically, it's
negative unless we're
talking about
maybe luxury goods,
where you know,
the more expensive,
the more people
actually want it.
I mean, if we're talking
about actual economic demand,
that's probably
definitely negative.
It doesn't have to be,
you know, clearly linear,
so that you can actually
make it linear, transform it
into something linear.
So for example, you have
this like multiplicative
relationship, PV equals nRT,
which is the Ideal gas law.
If you want to actually
write this relationship,
if you want to predict
what the pressure is
going to be as a function of
the volume and the temperature--
and well, let's assume that
n is the Avogadro constant,
and let's assume that the
radius is actually fixed.
Then you take the log on each
side, so you get PV equals nRT.
So what that means is that
log PV is equal to log nRT.
So that means log P plus log V
is equal to the log nR plus log
T. So we said that R is
constant, so this is actually
your constant.
I'm going to call it a.
And then that
means that log P is
equal to minus log V. That
log P is equal to a minus log
V plus log T. OK?
And so in particular, if I
write b equal to negative 1
and c equal to plus 1,
this gives me the formula
that I have here.
Now again, it might be the case
that this is the ideal gas law.
So in practice, if I
start recording pressure,
and temperature, and volume, I
might make measurement errors,
there might be slightly
different conditions
in such a way that I'm not
going to get exactly those.
And I'm just going to
put this little twiddle
to account for the fact
that the points that I'm
going to be recording
for log pressure,
log volume, and log
temperature are not going
to be exactly on one line.
OK, they're going to be close.
Actually, in those
physics experiments,
usually, they're very close
because the conditions
are controlled under
lab experiments.
So it means that the
noise is very small.
But for other cases,
like demand and prices,
it's not a law of physics,
and so this must change.
Even the linear structure is
probably not clear, right.
At some points,
there's probably going
to be some weird
curvature happening.
All right, so this slide is
just to tell you maybe you
don't have, obviously,
a linear relationship,
but maybe you do
if you start taking
logs exponentials, squares.
You can sometimes take the
product of two variables,
things like this, right.
So this is variable
transformation,
and it's mostly
domain-specific, so we're not
going to go into
more details of this.
Any questions?
All right, so now I'm
going to be giving--
so if we start thinking
a little more about what
these coefficients
should be, well,
remember-- so
everybody's clear why
I don't put the little i here?
Right, I don't put the
little i because I'm just
talking about a generic
x and a generic y,
but the observations
are x1, y1, right.
So typically, on
the blackboard I'm
often going to write only xy,
but the data really is x1,
y1, all the way to xn, yn.
So those are those points in
this two dimensional plot.
But I think of those as being
independent copies of the pair
xy.
They have to have--
to contain their relationship.
And so when I talk
about distribution
of those random variables, I
talk about the distribution
of xy, and that's the same.
All right, so the first
thing you might want to ask
is, well, if I have an
infinite amount of data,
what can I hope to
get for a and b?
If my simple size
goes to infinity,
then I should actually
know exactly what
the distribution of xy is.
And so there should
be an a and a b
that captures this linear
relationship between y and x.
And so in particular,
we're going
to try to ask the population,
or theoretic, values of a and b,
and you can see that
you can actually
compute them explicitly.
So let's just try to find how.
So as I said, we have
a bunch of points
on this line close
to a line, and I'm
trying to find the best fit.
All right, so this
guy is not a good fit.
This guy is not a good fit.
And we know that this guy
is a good fit somehow.
So we need to mathematically
formulate the fact
that this line here is
better than this line here
or better than this line here.
So what we're trying to do
is to create a function that
has values that are
smaller for this curve
and larger for these two curves.
And the way we do it is
by measuring the fit,
and the fit is essentially
the aggregate distance
of all the points to the curve.
And there's many
ways I can measure
the distance to a curve.
So if I want to find so--
let's just open a parenthesis.
If I have a point
here-- so we're
going to do it for
one point at a time.
So if I have a point,
there's many ways
I can measure its distance
to the curve, right?
I can measure it like that.
That is one distance
to the curve.
I can measure it like that by
having a right angle here that
is one distance to the curve.
Or I can measure it like that.
That is another distance
to the curve, right.
There's many ways
I can go for it.
It turns out that
one is actually
going to be fairly
convenient for us,
and that's the one that says,
let's look at the square
of the value of x on the curve.
So if this is the curve,
y is equal to a plus bx.
Now, I'm going to think of
this point as a random point,
capital X, capital
Y, so that means
that it's going to be x1,
y1 or x2, y2, et cetera.
Now, I want to
measure the distance.
Can somebody tell me
which of the three--
the first one, the second
one, or the third one--
this formula, expectation of y
minus a minus bx squared is--
which of the three
is it representing?
AUDIENCE: The second one.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
The second one
where I have the right angle?
OK, everybody agrees with this?
Anybody wants to vote
for something else?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The third one?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
The third one?
Everybody agrees
with the third one?
So by default, everybody's
on the first one?
Yeah, it is the vertical
distance actually.
And the reason is if it was the
one with the straight angle,
with the right angle,
it would actually
be a very complicated
mathematical formula,
so let's just see y, right?
And by y, I mean y.
OK, so this means that this
is my x, and this is my y.
All right, so that means
that this point is xy.
So what I'm measuring
is the difference
between y minus
a plus b times x.
This is the thing I'm going
to take the expectation off--
the square and then
the expectation-- so a
plus b times x, if this is
this line, this is this point.
So that's this value here.
This value here is
a plus bx, right?
So what I'm really
measuring is the difference
between y and N plus bx,
which is this distance here.
And since I like things
like Pythagoras theorem,
I'm actually going
to put a square here
before I take the expectation.
So now this is a
random variable.
This is this random variable.
And so I want a number,
so I'm going to turn it
into a deterministic number.
And the way I do this is
by taking expectation.
And if you think expectations
should be close to average,
this is the same
thing as saying,
I want that in
average, the y's are
close to the a plus bx, right?
So we're doing it
in expectation,
but that's going to
translate into doing it
in average for all the points.
All right, so this is the
thing I want to measure.
So that's this
vertical distance.
Yeah?
OK.
This is my fault actually.
Maybe we should
close those shades.
OK, I cannot do just
one at a time, sorry.
All right, so now that I do
those vertical distances,
I can ask-- well, now,
I have this function,
right-- to have a function that
takes two parameters a and b,
maps it to the expectation
of y minus a plus bx squared.
Sorry, the square is here.
And I could ask, well,
this is a function that
measures the fit of the
parameters a and b, right?
This function should be small.
The value of this
function here, function
of a and b that measures
how close the point xy is
to the line a plus
b times x while y
is equal to a plus b
times x in expectation.
OK, agreed?
This is what we just said.
Again, if you're not
comfortable with the reason why
you get expectations, just
think about having data points
and taking the average
value for this guy.
So it's basically an
aggregate distance
of the points to their line.
OK, everybody agrees this
is a legitimate measure?
If all my points were on the
line-- if my distribution--
if y was actually equal
to a plus bx for some a
and b then this function
would be equal to 0
for the correct a and b, right?
If they are far--
well, it's going
to depend on how much
noise I'm getting,
but it's still going to be
minimized for the best one.
So let's minimize this thing.
So here, I don't make any--
again, sorry.
I don't make an assumption on
the distribution of x or y.
Here, I assume, somehow,
that the variance of x
is not equal to 0.
Can somebody tell me why?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Not really a
question-- the slides,
you have y minus a minus bx
quantity squared expectation
of that, and here you've written
square of the expectation.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
No, here I'm actually
in the expectation
of the square.
If I wanted to write the
square of the expectation,
I would just do this.
So let's just make it clear.
Right?
Do you want me to put an
extra set of parenthesis?
That's what you want me to do?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's just
confusing with the [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: OK, that's
the one that makes sense, so
the square of the expectation?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Oh, the
expectation of the square,
sorry.
Yeah, dyslexia.
All right, any question?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Does this assume
that the error is Gaussian?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: No.
AUDIENCE: I mean, in
the sense that like,
if we knew that the
error was, like,
even the minus followed
like-- so even the minus x
to the fourth distribution,
would we want to minimise
the expectation of what
the fourth power of y minus
a equals bx in order to get
[? what the ?] [? best is? ?]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Why?
So you know the answers
to your question,
so I just want you to
use the words that--
right, so why would you want
to use the fourth power?
AUDIENCE: Well,
because, like, we
want to more strongly
penalize deviations
because we'd expect very
large deviations to be
very rare, or more
rare, than it would
with the Gaussian
[INAUDIBLE] power.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah so,
that would be the maximum likely
estimator that you're
describing to me, right?
I can actually
write the likelihood
of a pair of numbers ab.
And if I know this,
that's actually
what's going to come
into it because I
know that the density is
going to come into play when
I talk about there.
But here, I'm just
talking about--
this is a mechanical tool.
I'm just saying, let's minimize
the distance to the curve.
Another thing I could have
done is take the absolute value
of this thing, for example.
I just decided to take the
square root before I did it.
OK, so regardless
of what I'm doing,
I'm just taking the
squares because that's just
going to be convenient for me
to do my computations for now.
But we don't have
any statistical model
at this point.
I didn't say anything--
that y follows this.
X follows this.
I'm just doing
minimal assumptions
as we go, all right?
So the variance of
x is not equal to 0?
Could somebody tell me why?
What would my cloud point
look like if the variance of x
was equal to 0?
Yeah, they would all
be at the same point.
So it's going to be hard for
me to start fitting in a line,
right?
I mean, best case
scenario, I have this x.
It has variance, zero, so
this is the expectation of x.
And all my points have
the same expectation,
and so, yes, I could
probably fit that line.
But that wouldn't help
very much for other x's.
So I need a bit of variance
so that things spread out
a little bit.
OK, I'm going to
have to do this.
I think it's just my--
All right, so I'm going to
put a little bit of variance.
And the other thing is here,
I don't want to do much more,
but I'm actually going to think
of x as having means zero.
And the way I do
this is as follows.
Let's define x tilde, which is
x minus the expectation of x.
OK, so definitely the
expectation of x tilde is what?
Zero, OK.
And so now I want to
minimize in ab, expectation
of y minus a plus b, x squared.
And the way I'm going to do this
is by turning x into x tilde
and stuffing the extra--
and putting the extra
expectation of x into the a.
So I'm going to write this as
an expectation of y minus a plus
b expectation of x--
which I'm going to a tilde--
and plus b x tilde.
OK?
And everybody agrees with this?
So now I have two
parameters, a tilde and b,
and I'm going to pretend
that now x tilde--
so now the role of x is played
by x tilde, which is now
a centered random variable.
OK, so I'm going to
call this guy a tilde,
but for my computations
I'm going to call it a.
So how do I find the
minimum of this thing?
Derivative equal to zero, right?
So here it's a quadratic thing.
It's going to be like that.
I take the derivative,
set it to zero.
So I'm first going to take
the derivative with respect
to a and set it equal to zero,
so that's equivalent to saying
that the expectation of--
well, here, I'm going
to pick up a 2--
y minus a plus bx
tilde is equal to zero.
And then I also have that the
derivative with respect to b is
equal to zero, which is
equivalent to the expectation
of-- well, I have a
negative sign somewhere,
so let me put it here--
minus 2x tilde, y
minus a plus bx tilde.
OK, see that's why I don't want
to put too many parenthesis.
OK.
So I just took the
derivative with respect
to a, which is just
basically the square,
and then I have a negative 1
that comes out from inside.
And then I take the
derivative with respect
to b, and since b has x tilde.
In [? factor, ?] it
comes out as well.
All right, so the minus 2's
really won't matter for me.
And so now I have two equations.
The first equation,
while it's pretty simple,
it's just telling me that
the expectation of y minus a
is equal to zero.
So what I know is that a is
equal to the expectation of y.
And really that
was a tilde, which
implies that the a
I want is actually
equal to the
expectation of y minus b
times the expectation of x.
OK?
Just because a tilde is a plus
b times the expectation of x.
So that's for my a.
And then for my b, I
use the second one.
So the second one tells me that
the expectation of x tilde of y
is equal to a plus b times
the expectation of x tilde
which is zero, right?
OK?
But this a is actually
a tilde in this problem,
so it's actually a plus
b expectation of x.
Now, this is the
expectation of the product
of two random variables, but
x tilde is centered, right?
It's x minus expectation of
x, so this thing is actually
equal to the covariance
between x and y
by definition of covariance.
So now I have everything
I need, right.
How do I just--
I'm sorry about that.
So I have everything I need.
Now, I now have two
equations with two unknowns,
and all I have to do is
to basically plug it in.
So it's essentially telling
me that the covariance of xy--
so the first equation tells
me that the covariance of xy
is equal to a plus b expectation
of x, but a is expectation of y
minus b expectation of x.
So it's-- well, actually,
maybe I should start with b.
Oh, sorry.
OK, I forgot one thing.
This is not true, right.
I forgot this term.
x tilde multiplies x
tilde here, so what
I'm left with is x tilde--
it's minus b times the
expectation of x tilde squared.
So that's actually minus
b times the variance of x
tilde because x tilde
is already centered,
which is actually
the variance of x.
So now I have that this thing
is actually a plus b expectation
of x minus b variance of x.
And I also have that a
is equal to expectation
of y minus b expectation of x.
So if I sum the two, those
guys are going to cancel.
Those guys are going to cancel.
And so what I'm going to be
left with is covariance of xy
is equal to expectation
of x, expectation of y,
and then I'm left with
this term here, minus
b times the variance of x.
And so that tells me that b--
why do I still have
the variance there?
AUDIENCE: So is the
covariance really
the expectation of x tilde
times y minus expectation of y?
Because y is not
centered, correct?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK, but x
is still the center.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: But x
is still the center, right.
So you just need
to have one that's
centered for this to work.
Right, I mean, you can check it.
But basically when
you're going to have
the product of the expectations,
you only need one of the two
in the product to be zero.
So the product is zero.
OK, why do I keep my--
so I get a, a, and
then the b expectation.
OK, so that's probably
earlier that I made a mistake.
So I get-- so this was a tilde.
Let's just be clear about the--
So that tells me that a tilde--
maybe it's not super
fair of me to--
yeah, OK, I think I know
where I made a mistake.
I should not have centered.
I wanted to make my life
easier, and I should not
have done that.
And the reason is a
tilde depends on b,
so when I take the
derivative with respect
to b, what I'm left with here--
since a tilde
depends on b, when I
take the derivative of
this guy, I actually
don't get a tilde here,
but I really get--
so again, this was not--
so that's the first one.
This is actually x here--
because when I take the
derivative with respect to b.
And so now, what I'm left with
is that the expectation-- so
yeah, I'm basically left
with nothing that helps.
So I'm sorry about.
Let's start from the
beginning because this is not
getting us anywhere, and a
fix is not going to help.
So let's just do it again.
Sorry about that.
So let's not center anything
and just do brute force
because we're going to--
b x squared.
All right.
Partial, with respect
to a, is giving
equal zero is
equivalent, so my minus 2
is going to cancel, right.
So I'm going to actually
forget about this.
So it's actually telling
me that the expectation
of y minus a plus bx
is equal to zero, which
is equivalent to a plus
b expectation of x, is
equal to the expectation of y.
Now, if I take the
derivative with respect to
b and set it equal to
zero, this is telling me
that the expectation of--
well, it's the same thing
except that this time I'm
going to pull out an x.
This guy is equal to zero--
this guy is not here--
and so that implies that
the expectation of xy
is equal to a times
the expectation of x,
plus b times the
expectation of x square.
OK?
All right, so the first one is
actually not giving me much,
so I need to actually work
with the two of those guys.
So I'm going to take the first--
so let me rewrite those two
inequalities that I have.
I have a plus b, e of
x is equal to e of y.
And then I have e of xy.
OK, and now what I do is
that I multiply this guy.
So I want to cancel one
of those things, right?
So what I'm going to--
so I'm going to take
this guy, and I'm
going to multiply it by e of
x and take the difference.
So I do times e of x, and then
I take the sum of those two,
and then those two terms
are going to cancel.
So then that tells
me that b times e
of x squared, plus the
expectation of xy is equal to--
so this guy is the
one that cancelled.
Then I get this guy
here, expectation
of x times the expectation
of y, plus the guy that
remains here--
which is b times the
expectation of x square.
So here I have b expectation
of x, the whole thing squared.
And here I have b
expectation of x square.
So if I pull this guy
here, what do I get?
b times the variance of x, OK?
So I'm going to move here.
And this guy here, when
I move this guy here,
I get the expectation
of x times y,
minus the expectation of x
times the expectation of y.
So this is actually telling me
that the covariance of x and y
is equal to b times
the variance of x.
And so then that
tells me that b is
equal to covariance of xy
divided by the variance of x.
And that's why I actually
need the variance
of x to be non-zero because
I couldn't do that otherwise.
And because if it
was, it would mean
that b should be
plus infinity, which
is what the limit of this
guy is when the variance goes
to zero or negative infinity.
I can not sort them out.
All right, so I'm
sorry about the mess,
but that should be more clear.
Then a, of course,
you can write it
by plugging in the
value of b, so you
know it's only a function
of your distribution, right?
So what are the characteristics
of the distribution--
so distribution can
have a bunch of things.
It can have movements
of order 4, of order 26.
It can have heavy
tails or light tails.
But when you compute
least squares,
the only thing that
matters are the variance
of x, the expectation
of the individual ones--
and really what captures how
y changes when you change x,
is captured in the covariance.
The rest is really
just normalization.
It's just telling you, I want
things to cross the y-axis
at the right place.
I want things to cross the
x-axis at the right place.
But the slope is really captured
by how much more covariance
you have relative to
the variance of x.
So this is essentially setting
the scale for the x-axis,
and this is telling
you for a unit scale,
this is the unit of y
that you're changing.
OK, so we have explicit forms.
And what I could do, if I
wanted to estimate those things,
is just say, well again, we
have expectations, right?
The expectation of xy minus the
product of the expectations,
I could replace
expectations by averages
and get an empirical
covariance just
like we can replace the
expectations for the variance
and get a sample covariance.
And this is basically what
we're going to be doing.
All right, this is
essentially what you want.
The problem is that if
you view it that way,
you sort of prevent yourself
from being able to solve
the multivariate problem.
Because it's only in
the univariate problem
that you have closed form
solutions for your problem.
But if you actually
go to multivariate,
this is not where you want
to replace expectations
by averages.
You actually want to replace
expectation by averages here.
And once you do
it here, then you
can actually just solve
the minimisation problem.
OK, so one thing that
arises from this guy
is that this is an
interesting formula.
All right, think about it.
If I have that y is a
plus bx plus some noise.
Things are no
longer on something.
I have that y is equal to
a bx plus some noise, which
is usually denoted by epsilon.
So that's the
distribution, right?
If I tell you the
distribution of x, and I
say y is a plus b epsilon--
I tell you the
distribution of y,
and if [? they mean ?] that
those two are independent,
you have a distribution on y.
So what happens is that I can
actually always say-- well, you
know, this is
equivalent to saying
that epsilon is equal to
y minus a plus bx, right?
I can always write
this as just--
I mean, as tautology.
But here, for those guys--
this is not for any guy, right.
This is really for
the best fit, a
and b, those ones that
satisfy this gradient is
equal to zero thing.
Then what we had is that
the expectation of epsilon
was equal to expectation
of y minus a plus
b expectation of x by linearity
of the expectation, which
was equal to zero.
So for this best
fit we have zero.
Now, the covariance
between x and y--
Between, sorry, x
and epsilon, is what?
Well, it's the
covariance between x--
and well, epsilon was
y minus a plus bx.
Now, the covariance is
bilinear, so what I have
is that the
covariance of this is
the covariance of xn times y--
sorry, of x and y, minus
the variance-- well,
minus a plus b,
covariance of x and x,
which is the variance of x?
Covariance of xy minus
a plus b variance of x.
OK, I didn't write it.
So here I have
covariance of xy is
equal to b variance of x, right?
Covariance of xy.
Yeah, that's because they cannot
do that with the covariance.
Yeah, I have those
averages again.
No, because this
is centered, right?
Sorry, this is centered,
so this is actually
equal to the expectation of
x times y minus a plus bx.
The covariance is
equal to the product
just because this insight
is actually centered.
So this is the
expectation of x times y
minus the expectation of a times
the expectation of x, plus b
minus b times the
expectation of x squared.
Well, actually maybe I
should not really go too far.
So this is actually
the one that I need.
But if I stop here, this is
actually equal to zero, right.
Those are the same equations.
OK?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What are
we doing right now?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
So we're just saying
that if I actually believe that
this best fit was the one that
gave me the right
parameters, what would
that imply on the noise
itself, on this epsilon?
So here we're
actually just trying
to find some necessary condition
for the noise to hold--
for the noise.
And so those conditions are,
that first, the expectation
is zero.
That's what we've got here.
And then, that the covariance
between the noise and x
has to be zero as well.
OK, so those are
actually conditions
that the noise must satisfy.
But the noise was just not
really defined as noise itself.
We were just
saying, OK, if we're
going to put some assumptions
on the epsilon, what
do we better have?
So the first one is that
it's centered, which is good,
because otherwise, the noise
would shift everything.
So now when you look at a
linear regression model--
typically, if you open a book,
it doesn't start by saying,
let the noise be the
difference between y
and what I actually
want y to be.
It says let y be a
plus bx plus epsilon.
So conversely, if we assume that
this is the model that we have,
then we're going to have
to assume that epsilon--
we're going to assume
that epsilon is centered,
and that the covariance
between x and epsilon is zero.
Actually, often, we're
going to assume much more.
And one way to ensure that
those two things are satisfied
is to assume that x is
independent of epsilon,
for example.
If you assume that x is
independent of epsilon,
of course the covariance
is going to be zero.
Or we might assume that
the conditional expectation
of epsilon, given x, is equal
to zero, then that implies that.
OK, now the fact that it's
centered is one thing.
So if we make this assumption,
the only thing it's telling us
is that those ab's that come--
right, we started from there.
y is equal to a plus bx plus
some epsilon for some a,
for some b.
What it turns out is that
those a's and b's are actually
the ones that you would get
by solving this expectation
of square thing.
All right, so when you asked--
back when you were following--
so when you asked,
you know, why don't we
take the square, for
example, or the power
4, or something like this--
then here, I'm saying, well, if
I have y is equal to a plus bx,
I don't actually need to put
too much assumptions on epsilon.
If epsilon is actually
satisfying those two things,
expectation is equal to
zero and the covariance
with x is equal to zero,
then the right a and b
that I'm looking for are
actually the ones that
come with the square--
not with power 4 or power 25.
So those are actually
pretty weak assumptions.
If we want to do
inference, we're
going to have to
assume slightly more.
If we want to use
T-distributions at some point,
for example, and we
will, we're going
to have to assume that epsilon
has a Gaussian distribution.
So if you want to start doing
more statistics beyond just
like doing this least square
thing, which is minimizing
the square of criterion,
you're actually
going to have to put
more assumptions.
But right now, we
did not need them.
We only need that epsilon
as mean zero and covariant
zero with x.
OK, so that was basically
probabilistic, right.
If I were to do
probability and I
were trying to model the
relationship between two
random variables, x
and y, in the form
y is a plus bx plus some noise,
this is what would come out.
Everything was expectations.
There was no data involved.
So now let's go to the
data problem, which is now,
I do not know what
those expectations are.
In particular, I don't know what
the covariance of x and y is,
and I don't know with
the expectation of x
and the expectation of y r.
So I have data to do that.
So how am I going to do this?
Well, I'm just
going to say, well,
if I want x1, y1,
xn, yn, and I'm going
to assume that
they're [? iid. ?]
And I'm actually going
to assume that they
have some model, right.
So I'm going to assume
that I have that a--
so that Yi follows
the same model.
So epsilon i
[? rad, ?] and I won't
say that expectation of epsilon
i is zero and covariance of xi,
epsilon i is equal to zero.
So I'm going to put the
same model on all the data.
So you can see that a is
not ai, and b is not bi.
It's the same.
So as my data
increases, I should
be able to recover
the correct things--
as the size of my
data increases.
OK, so this is what the
statistical problem look like.
You're given the points.
There is a true line
from which this point
was generated, right.
There was this line.
There was a true ab that
I use to draw this plot,
and that was the line.
So first I picked an
x, say uniformly at
on this intervals, 0 to 2.
I said that was this one.
Then I said well, I
want y to be a plus bx,
so it should be
here, but then I'm
going to add some noise
epsilon to go away again
back from this line.
And that's actually me, here, we
actually got two points correct
on this line.
So there's basically
two epsilons
that were small enough
that the dots actually
look like they're on the line.
Everybody's clear
about what I'm drawing?
So now of course if
you're a statistician,
you don't see this.
You only see this.
And you have to
recover this guy,
and it's going to
look like this.
You're going to have an
estimated line, which
is the red one.
And the blue line, which is
the true one, the one that
actually generated the data.
And your question is,
while this line corresponds
to some parameters
a hat and b hat,
how could I make sure that those
two lines-- how far those two
lines are?
And one to address
this question is
to say how far is a from a hat,
and how far is b from b hat?
OK?
Another question, of
course, that you may ask
is, how do you find
a hat and b hat?
And as you can see, it's
basically the same thing.
Remember, what was a-- so b
was the covariance between x
and y divided by the
variance of x, right?
We check and rewrite this.
The expectation of
xy minus expectation
of x times the
expectation of y, divided
by expectation of x squared
minus expectation of x.
The whole thing's--
OK?
If you look at the
expression for b hat,
I basically replaced all
the expectations by bars.
So I said, well,
this guy I'm going
to estimate by an average.
So that's the xy
bar, and is 1 over n,
[? sum ?] from [? i co ?]
1, to n of Xi, times Yi.
x bar, of course, is just
the one that we're used to.
And same for y bar.
X squared bar, the
one that's here,
is the average of the squares.
And x bar square is the
square of the average.
OK, so you just basically
replace this guy by x bar,
this guy by y bar, this
guy by x square bar,
and this guy by x
bar and no square.
OK, so that's basically
one way to do it.
Everywhere you see
an expectation,
you replace it by an average.
That's the usual
statistical hammer.
You can actually be slightly
more subtle about this.
And as an exercise,
I invite you--
just to make sure that you know
how to do this competition,
it's going to be exactly the
same kind of competitions
that we've done.
But as an exercise,
you can check
that if you actually
look at say, well,
what I wanted to minimize here,
I had an expectation, right?
And I said, let's
minimize this thing.
Well, let's replace this
by an average first.
And now minimize.
OK, so if I do
this, it turns out
I'm going to actually
get the same result.
The minimum of the
average is basically--
when I replace the
average by-- sorry,
expectation by the average
and then minimize,
it's the same thing
as first minimizing and
then replacing expectation
by averages in this case.
Again, this is a much
more general principle
because if you
don't have a closed
form for the minimum like for
some, say, likelihood problems,
well, you might not
actually have a possibility
to just look at what the
formula looks like-- see where
the expectations show up-- and
then just plug in the averages
instead.
So this is the one you
want to keep in mind.
And again, as an exercise.
OK, so here, and then
you do expectation
replaced by averages.
And then that's the same
answer, and I encourage
you to solve the exercise.
OK, everybody's clear that this
is actually the same expression
for a hat and b hat that we had
before that we had for a and b
when we replaced the
expectations by averages?
Here, by the way, I minimize
the sum rather than the average.
It's clear to everyone that
this is the same thing, right?
Yep?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] sum
replacing it [INAUDIBLE]
minimize the
expectation, I'm assuming
it's switched with
the derivative
on the expectation [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
So we did switch
the derivative and the
expectation before you came,
I think.
All right, so
indeed, the picture
was the one that we
said, so visually, this
is what we're doing.
We're looking among
all the lines.
For each line, we
compute this distance.
So if I give you
another line there
would be another set of arrows.
You look at their length.
You square it.
And then you sum it
all, and you find
the line that has the minimum
sum of squared lengths
of the arrows.
All right, and those are the
arrows that we're looking at.
But again, you could actually
think of other distances,
and you would actually
get different--
you could actually get
different solutions, right.
So there's something called,
mean absolute deviation,
which rather than
minimizing this thing,
is actually minimizing the
sum from i to co 1 to n
of the absolute value
of y minus a plus bXi.
And that's not
something for which
you're going to have a closed
form, as you can imagine.
You might have something
that's sort of implicit,
but you can actually still
solve it numerically.
And this is something
that people also
like to use but way, way less
than the least squares one.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
What did I just what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
The sum of the absolute
values of Yi minus a plus bXi.
So it's the same except
I don't square here.
OK?
So arguably, you know,
predicting a demand
based on price is a
fairly naive problem.
Typically, what we
have is a bunch of data
that we've collected,
and we're hoping that,
together, they can help
us do a better prediction.
All right, so maybe I
don't have only the price,
but maybe I have a bunch
of other social indicators.
Maybe I know the competition,
the price of the competition.
And maybe I know a
bunch of other things
that are actually relevant.
And so I'm trying to find a way
to combine a bunch of points,
a bunch of measures.
There's a nice
example that I like,
which is people were
trying to measure something
related to your body
mass index, so basically
the volume of your-- the
density of your body.
And the way you can do
this is by just, really,
weighing someone and
also putting them
in some cubic meter of water
and see how much overflows.
And then you have
both the volume
and the mass of
this person, and you
can start computing density.
But as you can
imagine, you know,
I would not personally
like to go to a gym
when the first thing
they ask me is to just go
in a bucket of
water, and so people
try to find ways to measure this
based on other indicators that
are much easier to measure.
For example, I don't know,
the length of my forearm,
and the circumference of
my head, and maybe my belly
would probably be
more appropriate here.
And so you know, they
just try to find something
that actually makes sense.
And so there's
actually a nice example
where you can show
that if you measure--
I think one of the
most significant
was with the circumference
of your wrist.
This is actually a very good
indicator of your body density.
And it turns out that if you
stuff all the bunch of things
together, you might actually
get a very good formula that
explains things.
All right, so what
we're going to do
is rather than saying
we have only one x
to explain y's,
let's say we have
20 x's that we're trying
to combine to explain y.
And again, just like assuming
something of the form,
y is a plus b times x was the
simplest thing we could do,
here we're just going to
assume that we have y is a plus
b1, x1 plus b2, x2, plus b3, x3.
And we can write
it in a vector form
by writing that Yi is
Xi transposed b, which
is now a vector plus epsilon i.
OK, and here, on
the board, I'm going
to have a hard time
doing boldface,
but all these things are
vectors except for y,
which is a number.
Yi is a number.
It's always the
value of my y-axis.
So even if my x-axis lives on--
this is x1, and this is x2, y
is really just the real valued
function.
And so I'm going to get
a bunch of points, x1,y1,
and I'm going to see
how much they respond.
So for example, my
body density is y,
and then all the x's are
a bunch of other things.
Agreed with that?
So this is an equation that
holds on the real line,
but this guy here is an r
p, and this guy's an rp.
It's actually common to
talk to call b, beta,
when it's a vector, and that's
the usual linear regression
notation.
Y is x beta plus epsilon.
So x's are called
explanatory variables.
y is called explained variable,
or dependent variable,
or response variable.
It has a bunch of names.
You can use whatever you
feel more comfortable with.
It should actually
be explicit, right,
so that's all you care about.
Now, what we typically do
is that rather-- so you
notice here, that there's
actually no intercept.
If I actually fold that
back down to one dimension,
there's actually a is
equal to zero, right?
If I go back to p
is equal to 1, that
would imply that Yi is,
well, say, beta times
x plus epsilon i.
And that's not good, I
want to have an intercept.
And the way I do this,
rather than writing
a plus this, and
you know, just have
like an overload of notation,
what I am actually doing
is that I fold back.
I fold my intercept
back into my x.
And so if I measure
20 variables,
I'm going to create a
21st variable, which
is always equal to 1.
OK, so you should need
to think of x as being 1.
And then x1 xp.
And sorry, xp minus 1, I guess.
OK, and now this is an rp.
I'm always going to assume
that the first one is 1.
I can always do that.
If I have a table of data--
if my data is given to me
in an Excel spreadsheet--
and here I have the density
that I measured on my data,
and then maybe here
I have the height,
and here I have the
wrist circumference.
And I have all these things.
All I have to do is to create
another column here of ones,
and I just put 1-1-1-1-1.
OK, that's all I have to
do to create this guy.
Agreed?
And now my x is going to
be just one of those rows.
So that's this is
Xi, this entire row.
And this entry here is Yi.
So now, for my
noise coefficients,
I'm still going to
ask for the same thing
except that here, the
covariance is not between x--
between one random variable
and another random variable.
It's between a random vector
and a random variable.
OK, how do I measure the
covariance between a vector
and a random variable?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Yeah, so basically--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah, I
mean, the covariance vector
is equal to 0 is the same thing
as [INAUDIBLE] equal to zero,
but yeah, this is basically
thought of entry-wise.
For each coordinate of x,
I want that the covariance
between epsilon and this
coordinate of x is equal to 0.
So I'm just asking this
for all coordinates.
Again, in most
instances, we're going
to think that epsilon
is independent
of x, and that's something we
can understand without thinking
about coordinates.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] like
what if beta equals alpha
[INAUDIBLE]?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: I'm sorry,
can you repeat the question?
I didn't hear.
AUDIENCE: Is this the
parameter of beta, a parameter?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah,
beta is the parameter
we're looking for, right.
Just like it was the pair ab has
become the whole vector of beta
now.
AUDIENCE: And
what's [INAUDIBLE]??
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Well, can
you think of an intercept
of a function that take--
I mean, there is one actually.
There's the one
for which betas--
all the betas that
don't correspond
to the vector of all
ones, so the intercept
is really the weight
that I put on this guy.
That's the beta that's
going to come to this guy,
but we don't really
talk about intercept.
So if x lives in two
dimensions, the way
you want to think
about this is you
take a sheet of paper
like that, so now I
have points that live
in three dimensions.
So let's say one
direction here is x1.
This direction is x2,
and this direction is y.
And so what's going
to happen is that I'm
going to have my points
that live in this three
dimensional space.
And what I'm trying
to do when I'm
trying to do a linear
model for those guys--
when I assume a linear model.
What I assume is that there's
a plane in those three
dimensions.
So think of this guy
as going everywhere,
and there's a plane close to
which all my points should be.
That's what's happening
in two dimensional.
If you see higher dimensions
then congratulations to you,
but I can't.
But you know, you can definitely
formalize that fairly easily
mathematically and just
talk about vectors.
So now here, if I talk about the
least square error estimator,
or just the least squares
estimator of beta,
it's simply the same
thing as before.
Just like we said--
so remember, you
should think of as beta
as being both the
pair a b generalized.
So we said, oh, we wanted to
minimize the expectation of y
minus a plus bx squared, right?
Now, so that's in--
for p is equal to 1.
Now for p lower
than or equal to 2,
we're just going to write it
as y minus x transpose beta
squared.
OK, so I'm just trying to
minimize this quantity.
Of course, I don't
have access to this,
so what I'm going to do
with them going to replace
my expectation by an average.
So here I'm using the notation
t because beta is the true one,
and I don't want you to just--
so here, I have a variable
t that's just moving around.
And so now I'm going to take
the square of this thing.
And when I minimize this over
all t in rp, the arc min,
the minimum is attained at beta
hat, which is my estimator.
OK?
So if I want to
actually compute--
yeah?
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry,
on the last slide
did we require the expectation
of [INAUDIBLE] to be zero?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: You
mean the previous slide?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
[INAUDIBLE]
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So again,
I'm just defining an estimator
just like I would tell you,
just take the estimator that
has coordinates for everywhere.
AUDIENCE: So I'm saying like
[? in that sign, ?] we'll say
the noise [? terms ?] we want to
satisfy the covariance of that
[? side. ?] We also want them
to satisfy expectation of each
[? noise turn ?] zero?
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: And
so the answer is yes.
I was just trying to think
if this was captured.
So it is not
captured in this guy
because this is just telling
me that the expectation
of epsilon i minus expectation
of some i is equal to zero.
OK, so yes I need to have
that epsilon has mean zero--
let's assume that
expectation of epsilon
is zero for this problem.
And we're going
to need something
about some sort of question
about the variance being
not equal to zero, right, but
this is going to come up later.
So let's think for one second
about doing the same approach
as we did before.
Take the partial
derivative with respect
to the first coordinate
of t, with respect
to the second coordinate
to the third coordinate
of t, et cetera.
So that's what we did before.
We had two equations,
and we reconciled them
because it was fairly
easy to solve, right?
But in general,
what's going to happen
is we're going to have
a system of equations.
We're going to have a system
of p equations, one for each
of the coordinates of t.
And we're going to have p
unknowns, each coordinate of t.
And so we're going to
have the system to solve--
actually, i turns out it's
going to be a linear system.
But it's not going
to be something
that we're going to be able to
solve coordinate by coordinate.
It's going to be
annoying to solve.
You know, you can guess that
what's going to happen, right.
Here, it involved the covariance
between x and epsilon, right.
That's what it involved
to understand--
sorry, the correlation
between x and y
to understand how the
solution of this problem was.
In this case,
there's going to be
only the covariance between
x1 and y, x2 and y, x3, et
cetera, all the way to xp and y.
There's also going to be all
the cross covariances between xj
and xk.
And so this is going
to be a nightmare
to solve, like, in this system.
And what we do is that we go
on to using a matrix notation,
so that when we
take derivatives,
we talk about
gradients, and then we
can invert matrices and solve
linear systems in a somewhat
formal manner by just saying
that, if I want to solve
the system ax equals b--
rather than actually
solving this
for each coordinate
of x individually,
I just say that x is
equal to a inverse times.
So that's really why we're
going to the equation one,
because we have a
formalism to write that x
is the solution of the system.
I'm not telling you
that this is going
to be easy to solve numerically,
but at least I can write it.
And so here's how it goes.
I have a bunch of vectors.
So what are my vectors, right?
So I have x1--
oh, by the way,
I didn't actually
mention that when I
put the lowercase, when
I put the subscript, I'm
talking about the observation.
And when I put the
superscript, I'm
talking about the
coordinates, right?
So I have x1, which is
equal to x1, x1 [? 1, ?]
x 1p, x2, which is 1.
x2, 1, x2 p, all the way to
xn, which is 1, xn 1, x np.
All right, so those are n
observed x's, and then I
have another y1, y2, yn, that
comes paired with those guys.
OK?
So the first thing
is that I'm going
to stack those guys
into some vector
that I'm going to call y.
So maybe I should put
an arrow for the purpose
of the blackboard, and
it's just y1 to yn.
OK, so this is a vector in rn.
Now, if I want to stack
those guys together,
I can either create a long
vector of size n times p,
but the problem is that I lose
the role of who's a coordinate
and who's an observation.
And so it's actually
nicer for me
to just put those guys
next to each other
and create one new variable.
And so the way I'm going to do
this is-- rather than actually
stacking those guys like that,
I'm getting their transpose
and stack them as
rows of a matrix.
OK, so I'm going to
create a matrix, which
here is denoted typically by--
I'm going to write x double bar.
And here, I'm going to
actually just-- so since I'm
taking those guys like
this, the first column
is going to be only ones.
And then I'm going to have--
well, x1, 1, [? 1, ?] x1, p.
And here, I'm going
to have x n1, x np.
OK, so here the number of rows
is n, and the number of columns
is p.
One row per observation,
one column per coordinate.
And again, I make your life
miserable because this really
should be p minus 1
because I already used
the first one for this guy.
I'm sorry about that.
It's a bit painful.
So usually we don't even
write what's in there.
So we don't have
to think about it.
Those are just
vectors of size p.
OK?
So now that I
created this thing,
I can actually just basically
stack up all my models.
So Yi equals Xi transpose
beta plus epsilon i for all i
equal 1 to n.
This transforms into-- this
is equivalent to saying
that the vector y is
equal to the matrix x
times beta plus a matrix,
plus a vector epsilon,
where epsilon is just epsilon
1 to epsilon n, right.
So I have just
this system, which
I write as a matrix,
which really just consists
in stacking up all these
equations next to each other.
So now that I have this model--
this is the usual least squares
model.
And here, when I want to write
my least squares criterion
in terms of matrices, right?
My least squares
criterion, remember,
was sum from i equal 1 to n
of Yi minus Xi transposed beta
squared.
Well, here it's
really just the sum
of the square of the
coefficients of the vector
y minus x beta.
So this is actually
equal to the norm squared
of y minus x beta square.
That's just the square.
Norm is, by definition,
the sum of the square
of the coordinates.
And so now I can actually
talk about minimizing
a norm squared,
and here it's going
to be easier for me
to take derivatives.
All right, so we'll
do that next time.